remember this a Royal shuffle and
holding after some hand wringing and an
inflatable effigy hue Act to an estate
visit this time with even more pomp
pageantry and opinion but the Mayor of
London doesn't want any of it launching
a decidedly undiplomatic attack I don't
think we should be running out the red
carpet I don't think this should be a
state visit and why do I say that I
think the closest allies akin to the
best friend and thinking about best
friend is of course you stand shoulder
to shoulder with them at times of
adversity but you got to call them out
when you think they're wrong and there
are so many things about President
Donald Trump's policies that the
antithesis of our values in London but
also our values as a country but some
will welcome mr. Trump's brexit
cheerleading ambassador Wilson how are
you lovely to see you and the
president's national security advisor
told me his boss is determined to secure
a UK US trade deal after it even though
Teresa Mays time at number 10 is almost
up
of course the brexit negotiations will
be handled by her successor do you think
a No Deal is the best option for Britain
now well I think president Trump's made
it clear he looks forward to the day
when the US and the UK can negotiate a
bilateral trade deal that would be
beneficial to both countries and and to
see the will of the British people
carried out now beyond that I think it's
going to be up to the Conservative Party
in the first instance to pick a new
leader and then to see what what happens
in the negotiation process with the
European Union
but the dealmaker in chief has some
leverage in a britain that needs to find
partners I think Trump has really taken
a a quite predatory approach to these
trade negotiations with the UK he's
recognized that Teresa may is in a
vulnerable position following brexit she
is quite desperate to try and negotiate
new trading relationships for the the UK
and so Trump is going to try and take
advantage of that to seek as
preferential of a deal as he can for the
United States there is history and
willing on both sides of the Atlantic
with plenty of twists and turns along
the way this may be the era of the
unconventional but both countries want
to show it's still credible to expect
some subplots to the story here the u.s.
ambassador's residence where President
Trump will be staying and hosting a
dinner a chance to invite whoever he
wants there may well be some unscheduled
encounters here and some off-script
surprises but that doesn't mean that it
will shift the political dial Donald
Trump cares about the visuals and the
experience and with Teresa May just days
away from stepping down there is
arguably only so much they can achieve
and perhaps undo some of the president's
security team has already rolled into
town it's an unprecedented operation and
the most politically precarious of times
hoodie tillich sky knees